My biggest tips for an entrepreneur would be to differentiate yourself.
Why are you different? What's important about you?
Why does the customer need you?
And really have that really rehearsed and ready to go.
You got to visualize where you are headed and be very clear about it.
Take a Polaroid picture of where you're gonna be in a few years.
You've got to trust your gut even through the process of being able to afford advisers...
...and people with all this experience.
Still, check in with your gut along the way.
It's very important to be authentic,...
...and to be truly who you are from the beginning, all through the process.
The consumer will react to that;...
...treating people kindly...
...and being fair throughout the process,...
I believe in karma in business and it's really worked out for us here at Spanx.
I also think you should embrace what you don't know especially in the beginning...
...because what you don't know can become your greatest asset.
It ensures that you'll absolutely be doing things different from everybody else.
Don't solicit feedback on your product, your idea or your business just for validation purposes.
Be really careful about that.
You want to tell the people that can help move your idea forward.
But if you're just looking to your friend, co-worker, husband, wife for validation,...
...be careful because out of love and concern, a lot of people will express some concerns,...
...and it can stop a lot of multimillion-dollar ideas right in their tracks in the beginning.